y llegó el momento de profundizar en la
prensa internacional sobre los temas de
la actualidad y para ello entonces ya
está conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez
más de euros a feliz mañana de miércoles
vamos a abrir con información de
colombia sobre todo el panorama político
de cara a las elecciones legislativas en
marzo y las presidenciales en el mes de
mayo rosa respecto a los candidatos a
los comicios el país titula y cito la
política en colombia sigue siendo cosa
de hombres porque rosa bueno raúl buenos
días por distintas cuestiones empezamos
si te parece en el ámbito legislativo ya
que son las primeras elecciones a las
que nos dirigimos aquí en colombia en
primer lugar la periodista inés santa
eulalia recuerda que en la actual
legislatura de los 270 cargos electos
del congreso sólo 55 son mujeres lo que
representa menos de un 20 por ciento y
eso sitúa colombia 10 puntos por debajo
de la media de la región de américa
latina y el caribe pero por otro lado
también este artículo aparte de la
siguiente constatación en el incierto
panorama político nacional sólo hay una
certeza el próximo presidente será otra
vez un hombre y es que en relación a las
elecciones presidenciales señala la
periodista que de los 19 políticos que
tienen esos aspiraciones presidenciales
sólo cuatro son mujeres y que de estas
cuatro mujeres tres están diluidas
dentro de coalición es que los hombres
lideran en las encuestas de cara a las
primarias internas y que sólo una tiene
realmente posibilidades de oficializar
su candidatura presidencial
hablamos de ingrid betancourt y de aquí
pasamos al siguiente tema no relacionado
con colombia que hemos querido destacar
desafortunado sus comentarios
efectivamente y es que ayer se refirió
en un acto ingrid betancourt a las
mujeres que se hacen violar o
evidentemente desató en mucha polémica
esta formulación por la que ya se
disculpó así como lo titula el tiempo
pero esquerra esto nos tiene que
recordar que a veces cuando hay una
mujer entre tanto hombre se le atribuye
una cierta agenda feminista y sabemos
que nada más lejos de la realidad no que
ideología y género no tienen por qué ir
de la mano y cerramos con otro tema
también a de aquí de colombia y es que
el actual presidente e iván duque visitó
ayer el parlamento europeo y mientras
estaba dando un discurso en pro de la
democracia distintos europarlamentarios
protestaron con mensajes como paren la
matanza en colombia quien dio la orden
en relación al caso de los 'falsos
positivos' respeto a los acuerdos de paz
o con nombres de líderes asesinados aquí
en colombia bueno dejamos entonces a un
lado colombia y todo esto que tiene que
ver con las elecciones parlamentarias y
presidenciales para irnos a donde está
el foco mediático en estas últimas
semanas de tensión entre ucrania y rusia
y occidente vamos a economies lo analiza
desde el punto de vista de la soberanía
tecnológica rusa y se pregunta rusia
está tratando de construir su propio
gran cortafuegos un firewall y la
respuesta es que si tal y como señala
que dice que del mismo modo que putin
está pues intentando defender proteger
su área de influencia sobre el terreno
en la frontera con ucrania también
quiere controlar su espacio virtual de
las injerencias digamos de occidente y
que para ello junto con empresas
tribunales y tecnología estatal está
desarrollando un complejo proyecto de un
internet ruso bueno rosa y continuamos
con tecnología en una columna de opinión
publicada en el medio al yazira belén
fernández se define que el mosco es un
peligro para la seguridad porque bien
esta columna parte de una noticia que
salió hace unos días y es que no sé si
has oído que el on mars intentó comprar
digamos a un joven que se llama hayek
swing y que gestiona una cuenta de
twitter que se llama
el on jet y esta cuenta lo que hace es
rastrear los viajes en jet privado del
on mars y de otros magnates como jeff
bezos o bill gates básicamente lo más
ofreció al joven 5000 para que
suspendiera dicha cuenta una oferta que
el joven rechazó el on mars pues alegó
que esta cuenta era un peligro para su
seguridad personal y básicamente lo que
defiende la periodista es que es un poco
hipócrita que lo más se preocupe para
por su seguridad mientras le da un poco
igual la seguridad de la mayoría de la
población y pone algunos ejemplos y es
como por ejemplo su software autopilot
pues está comportando ciertos problemas
de seguridad y que distintos empleados
de tesla denuncian intimidación es
cuando los intentan señalar y también
puedes distintos proyectos que está
desarrollando este magnate como neural
link que pretende implantar microchips
en cerebros humanos y concluye esta
periodista al final está hipocresía se
relaciona con el consenso entre las
élites de que la seguridad la libertad y
la privacidad son privilegios reservados
para ellos fue que yo también hubiera
pensado como este muchacho cinco mil
dólares que me ofrece que me ofrezca el
mosto pues eso no es nada y yo pericia
entonces un poquito más rosa muchísimas
gracias entonces fue revista de prensa
nos vemos mañana con más vamos a saludar
a nuestro primer invitado el día